e aí galera casa o granada vocês não
seja tão bem junto do doente um catar e
toda aquela história de cachorro é
aquela história que quebra o cartório
faz pra essa torcida e do canadá papal
cada
quando o cara dorme acúmulo cataluppi a
primeira torcida do dia pior explosão em
hiroshima nagasaki do mundo e não
escolheu acordou a torcida que deu um
papo tão grande eu falei pronto fraturei
a coluna e eu gritei que passou o final
de semana todo e fazem show em são paulo
há muito frio lá logo minha garganta
fechou viro nariz ou catarro no próximo
final de semana só chorei lugar quente
grato ceará petrolina pernambuco e
juazeiro bahia e 18 levina o progresso
posições e está no meu site valeu é mais
falou o chefe pediu parei para analisar
porque assim foi um bom tempo como
assistir televisão mas aí eu estava na
casa do amigo meu da casa do braia e
ofendê-lo anotava assistir desenho eu
assistindo junto com o menino falei meu
deus do céu porque antigamente era o que
caverna do dragão que a caverna do
dragão no dragão é um desenho que os
meninos criança tem um parque ele se
distancia da mãe a wanda be quer ficar
ligado na de caio vai para a montanha
russa de perto da mãe vai parar eu tomo
nunca mais consegue voltar pra casa com
as crianças pensa eu tenho do céu não
vou me distanciar da minha mãe não pode
ser que nunca mais enquanto minha casa
nesse mundo é este que procurar comida
abrigo ou em qualquer lugar
as crianças só pensava na época eu não
vou não vou fugir de pé da minha mãe que
estão não vou ter o que comer não vou
ter o que beber vou ter abrigo eu voltei
e sucrilhos kellog's com o nescau 2.0
deve se passa inteiro eles tentando
voltar pra casa passa um ano dois anos
devem acabar eles não conseguem voltar
pra casa a crença da época pensava meu
deus do céu substância da minha mãe tá
bom eu nunca mais volto à minha casa meu
deus é duca as crianças ajuda as
crianças a criança que é inteligente
hoje é o que dora a aventureira as
graçado abre a porta de casa
a porta atrás da repar dada seiler da
criança atrasa a criança cresce dementia
a televisão adora e um hipopótamo maior
do que a tela o hipopótamo é tão grande
para mudar o disney channel tem a metade
da blue do hipopótamo na tela em que
contesta o medo e papá e come em papatam
era melhor botar até no facebook de uma
menina que eu conheço e dizer 'sim gente
vocês estão vendo a dignidade repita
comigo é tudo [ __ ] agora o desenho do
valor muito bom o pipop radical pepe o
desenho a marcha é a pepa o jorge a mãe
eo pai a mãe de jorge não vá brincar na
lama onde vai pra onde a lama onde joga
muito nas garras de calça saruel 2.0
cara aqui o jorge neto de um pouco ea
lama aqui do lado e jorge fica dançando
dota lama george jack o dodô jorge
brinca com perigo ele sabe que se a mãe
dele pegar na lama vai aconteceu a
chacina mas ele tá aonde tá aonde tá nem
aí você fica vidrado na tela você não
consegue pensar em mais nada lá o jorge
dançando o pé da lama ele vai se
aproximando da lama enquanto dança você
fique ou não jorge não jorge sai daí
george se aproximando da lama
por favor não vai falar mas jorge eu vou
mudar por jornal nacional tchau e você
fica vidrado da silva atleta você não
consegue pensar em mais nada chega a mãe
do cara entra na sala meu filho nosso
cachorro foi atropelado bomba mamãe eu
sei meu filho fica assim é muito triste
perder um cachorro é pelo amor de deus
jorge está na lama amor eu quero que
você comenta aqui embaixo que você acha
mais diferentes no desenho de hoje em
dia se tiver gostar do vídeo já sabe que
aquele boi vai gostei aqui no youtube
jet gente não sai daqui sem clicar em
gostei por favor e melhor volta lá no
facebook da postagem de um curto vídeo
novo não sei quem é e desenhos e volta
lá e quem curte e marcos os comentários
seu amigo que gosta muito de desenho é
de teresina é o link nos comentários que
dá pra comprar o ingresso com 50% de
disco não fui eu que falei viu beleza
não está mais aqui
quem falou foi bom a gente assume ó ó
enganei vocês só me escute ver que no
lado o editei segura olha pra assistir o
vídeo até aqui é nóis em berlim